YEARMIDDLE, A HANDFUL TO DEAL
WITH.
>> Dennis: VANECEK SHOT,
OUT IS THEIR PLAN
>> Dennis: PETER LAVIOLETTE ON
THE WASHINGTON
HE SAYS WHAT HE THINKS.
I BELIEVE THE MESSAGE WILLCOPP,.
BACK TO THE LINE IT COMESFF THED
CROSS ICE, AND VANECEK COMES OCS
WHERE THEY COULD HAVE SHOT THE
PUCK BUT  T,
SCHEIFELE GOT A STICK THE
NET.
THIRD OF THE YEAR FOR HIM.
AND THE CAPS HAVE THE GAME'S
OPENING G
SPACE IN THE HEART OF THE IC LE
MADE BY VANECEK.HE FRONT
OF THE NET!
THE BACK
BLACKHAWKS A COUPLE OF NIGHTS
AGO AGAINST
ANOTHER BIG SAVE.
VANECEK.
STANLEY TRIED TO DRIVE IT TO T
CAPITALS.
NICE CHANCE FOR THE JETS ARE ON.
INTO THE SLOT, SPRONG SHOT, THE
REBOUND,
THE SIDE BOARDS AND MORRISSEY
FINDS THE TOP CORNRN
THE TOP RIGHT.
BEAUTIFULLY PLACED LINE.
NATE SCHMIDT, PUCK IN FRONT OF
THE NET!
AND SCHEIFELE COULDN'T F F THE .
LEFT PAD SAVE DENNIS AND GETS M
BEHIND HELLEBUYCK, NO SHORT SID
TRY, AND VANECEK GETS ACROSS UPE
THE PUCK HIS
MANY GREAT SAVES TONIGHT.